depuis maintenant un mois jérôme et
livreurs à vélo au sein de l'association
versailles portage chaque jour il assure
les livraisons des commerçants de la
ville un service gratuit pour les
clients sur tous les territoires de
versailles grand parc
voilà d'accord enlevez le cargo s'il
vous plaît
ce matin il doit porter des boissons à
une personne âgée sur versailles
première étape récupérer les bouteilles
commandé auprès du commerçant
ce caviste et uns des 85 adhérents de
l'association un service financé par les
commerçants avec une participation de la
ville et de l'état
quoi
merci habitants
la livraison est prête jérôme repart sur
la route mais cette association ne vise
pas qu'à renforcer le commerce de
proximité et rendre service aux
personnes âgées ou handicapées c'est
aussi une entreprise d'insertion c'est
aussi l'emploi des personnes éloignées
donc qui sont soit au chômage soit qui
ont eu des problèmes des parcours
difficiles un divorce on peut se
retrouver très vite à la rue des
personnes qui ont fait un petit parcours
en prison pour des des petits débits et
qui ont leur donne une chance nous
retrouvons jérôme qui arrivent à
destination
pour lui cet emploi signe la fin de deux
ans de galère et pour chantal c'est un
service devenu indispensable
c'est très pratique on commençait là il
ya un petit peu c'est difficile pour
nous de porter les caisses de vin et les
packs de bouteilles donc c'est on trouve
que c'est vraiment très utile en 2012
près de 2500 personnes ont fait appel à
l'association pour certaines personnes
isolées
la venue de jérôme ou d'un de ses
collègues est la seule visite de la
semaine certaines personnes
ça fait des mois qu'ils restent chez eux
parce que bon
soin à z series et place assez lentement
donc voilà c'est mon père m'aide
le livre est un peu de tout jérôme
reprend la route il pourra conserver ce
travail deux ans au maximum le temps de
reprendre pied et de pédaler vers
d'autres horizons